mental health while your quarantine I am
here with a good friend of mine Lisa
Schumann she is a licensed clinical
social worker and she and I both served
the reproductive community we are used
to dealing with people in crisis covin
19 is added a layer of crisis and
isolation at an unprecedented level that
any of us have ever faced and Lisa thank
you so much for joining us this is such
a critical conversation at a really
tricky time in history yeah well thank
you for having me it's so true everyone
is really really feeling at their wit's
end of course people who've gone through
fertility treatment or other
difficulties in their life have this on
top of everything else but everybody is
really feeling stressed and I think you
know the most important thing for me to
start with is that regardless of what
you're feeling it's not wrong you know
less people are saying well you know my
friend is doing fine and look at the
people outside they seem to be enjoying
it and I'm going stir-crazy or I'm so
stressed and why is that or I can't
sleep I mean even my sleep medications
not working right better soft criticism
is the worst so above accept that your
journey is your journey and that you're
feeling however you feel that's it's
okay no matter how you feel
remember that movie The Kids Are Alright
yeah okay I keep saying that to all my
friends who have kids and they're
worried about under teaching and and
under parenting right now and all that I
keep saying the kids are alright yeah
the kid would be okay yes they will be
okay you know we're finding I've seen
some preliminary research that some of
the younger kids are actually who don't
really understand a lot of this yet
they're actually enjoying spending more
time with their parents they like that
that's not as hard it's the teens you
know I'm a little bit more worried about
because the teens are just by nature
developmentally they need to be socially
and it's very hard for them to be social
under these circumstances you know they
go on social media but it's not quite
the same and they're not really
connected to their friends which other
schools and so it can be really hard
especially hard for them and
teens and preteens are more prone to
depression and anxiety and all those
things so those kids probably are going
to struggle a little bit more how do
parents help them in that scenario
because I think that's also demographic
where you hear from a lot of parents oh
my my friend preteen my teen they're
moody already you know and then if you
add this kind of social isolation to it
how do parents support their their teens
during this time while also trying to
cope with their own anxiety what do you
recommend yes and the online learning
and then having to struggle between yeah
at home teacher and also holding down a
full-time job is really challenging it's
exhausting and I hope that more of the
schools will get on board and be you
know more helpful some are and some
aren't but the parents if the parents
can set up a schedule for the kids
I think that's ideal and I'm trying to
in for all of us who to stay on the
schedule is really really helpful
alright so schedule is really meaningful
are there any any signs events that
extra and anxiety or depression that
parents should be aware of when it comes
to their teen or themselves even you
know where it's time to call their
pediatrician or call their doctor to say
hey is there something you know
biochemical going on because we're not
getting enough sunlight or because
they're not sleeping well and their
melatonin is off which that makes the
cortisol higher you know is there any
any anything that people should be more
on the lookout for then for the normal
well certainly you know I'm preaching to
the choir here you know I know it's
really important to be able to have a
therapist or someone you can speak with
on how professional you can speak with
but certainly if the child is feeling
hopeless or helpless or seems to be
spending even more time in their room
and they would normally it's really good
to try to reach out to them and to try
to find out what's going on and if you
have a conflicted relationship with your
teen already then it really is helpful
to bring in a professional to trying and
maybe have some family therapy around
that and you know we do all kinds of
more if you would assume these days so
it's it's a really a useful tool we can
even in social isolation have
really productive therapy conversations
that's incredible so your missourah way
for being a great way that you recommend
people should even find therapists right
now is there a trusted source you know I
used to go into psychology today to like
because I love the profiles that they do
you know to find someone and they do
include reproductive therapists as well
in our space for those that are dealing
with infertility is there a trusted
source that you like to send people or
should they use one of the the apps that
are out there to try to find someone
yeah I mean I think that Psychology
Today is a great source you know someone
has a lot of experience that's better
than less experienced and also for
people in the fertility space I think
going to the American Society for
Reproductive Medicine is really
important because you want people who
are well skilled in this area and really
know what they're doing you don't want
to have to spend all your time
explaining to your therapist what's
happening to you okay so right now you
also you also work with a clinic itself
and you've already you know you've been
you've seen people for years and in some
cases there are reasons that they have
treatment delays or even treatment
cancellations so you've dealt with a
clientele who has stops and starts
already but we're seeing stops and
pauses at an unprecedented level because
of what's going on how are you you know
having those conversations with people
what are some of the coping strategies
to deal with the grief I mean I've read
an article of someone who said my fourth
and final IVF was just cancelled mm-hmm
well I will say you know it's a it's I'm
lucky enough to work with some fantastic
doctors and you know the doctors are
Reproductive Medicine Associates of
Connecticut are very very sensitive and
have a tremendous level of empathy for
their patients and so even though I
reach out to them and tell them I'm
happy to provide some really helpful
information about how to talk to
patients they are really skilled just by
on their own and so I think you know I
think it's really nice for patients you
know Kay if your doctor is sense
that goes a long way you know being able
to have those empathic skills is so key
during this time because there's some
things that they have control over and
other things they have no control over
yeah yeah yeah that's absolutely the
case oh my gosh okay can you distinguish
the difference between a coping
mechanism and self-care I feel like
people's self-care has been very
disrupted they can't go to the gym you
know they might be turning to more
alcohol than normal they might not be
doing all this sort of at home self-care
so what's the difference between a
coping strategy and healthy self-care is
there a difference well I think I think
we can kind of look at ways to make
yourself feel better or put yourself in
a better emotional story in kind of two
ways and so one is how can we decrease
our depressive or anxiety symptoms and
how can we raise the joy and that's hard
to do when we're not feeling like but
there are things that we can do to you
know make ourselves feel better whether
it's a little exercise with going
outside there are things that we can do
to decrease our stress like limiting TV
I know people feel completely captivated
by everything that's going on it was but
if you watch more than a half an hour of
what's happening it's really not
necessary it's just gonna raise your
stress levels if you don't spend time
with your family constructive way and
you don't have a schedule and you're
going to raise your stress levels if you
don't have coping mechanisms like
touching techniques and I have lots of
stress reduction techniques on a youtube
channel on my website if you don't use
meditation or yoga or other production
techniques that's gonna make you upset
and then the second piece really has to
do with control and you know that's
something that's so hard here everyone
is feeling out of control so what can we
do to make ourselves feel better well if
our body is feeling out of control not
only is it bad for us emotionally but
it's not great for our health right our
bodies have a natural fight-or-flight
response where we are expected to have a
reaction to a trigger that happens to us
but now we're having continual
Asians - triggers ongoing right first
yeah we have to leave our offices and
they were afraid for our jobs and then
our office gets closed and then we have
to stay home in social isolation and
then we can't hug our loved ones that's
returning looking for and I can't hug
everybody I wanted to have my lot today
hug I mean mice my kid is so tired of me
like tackling him for hugs I'm like
doing the the behind the back you know
hugs with him because he's like no we
want to be able to find places where we
do have some control in our lives
to kind of help balance ourselves a
little bit so even though people feel
stressed I really think it's a great
idea to try and that you can do this
with kids too there's so many nice ways
to find hobbies you know all the all the
schools are offering or almost all of
them are offering online classes
there's zoo tours and tours of museums
online his all the projects you can come
up with yourself even if you just want
to reorganize your living room it really
can help you feel stable longest if you
put your energy into something and then
you see a benefit for it it really can
help with everything else and your life
is so any control I love that we are I'm
thinking about two closets that need a
little attention right now but only way
to be great Oh organizing so that does
sound fun like maybe now it's a time for
a little premature spring cleaning or
something then that feeling of control
again or like clearing out I love that
and then it is true there are so many
great online online museum tours and so
forth and if we make them fun and not
more school because I think a lot of
people are kind of frustrated with that
like I don't want to do so much school
at home because school for so many kids
not mine to see home schools but for so
many students who are used to going
somewhere - for school and then coming
home for respite it's the same thing
that workers are facing I used to get to
go out of the house and then come home
from our respite and now it's all
jumbled up into one and
and so I think I think even changing
clothes you know is such a big deal it's
like okay I mean my work attire I had a
colleague today he put on one of his
fancy hats his grandpa had a collection
of fedoras and he has them and he looks
so stylish when he put some on he took a
video phone I said oh you got ready for
work today you would on do it
then when you're done with your day you
take off the fedora you put on your
sweats you have some kind of Delia
nation between work mode and now
relaxation kind of connected family mode
exactly exactly yeah all right see I do
have facebook live I put on a fancy
scarf I take off the scarf no one tells
me to use my inside voice and just stop
projecting at the camera all the time
what are your favorite self-care things
that you do or kind of stress reducers
what's one of your favorites well I love
to do meditation I love there's lots of
good meditation techniques
I think tapping even though it's may
seem a little bit out there and that can
be oh yeah I love this happen oh I'm
really helpful it's incredible I'm so
glad you brought that up because I have
plenty of panicky moments where it just
really works really work as always this
yep and there are lots of good YouTube
videos online that you can take a look
at there's lots of great stress
reduction techniques there's lots of
ways to do all sorts of things and also
to get your body moving get outside even
if it's just work you have some vitamin
D get some sunshine move your body
because if you're not if you're
depressed and you're moving your body
you're going to feel different there's
not a place that you can even do in
place or some putting YouTube videos is
one of them well the guy who put oil on
the floor and he just holds on to the
desk and starts making it into a
treadmill that's great myself I want to
do it with the cat
[Music]
love tilting my face up at the Sun right
now you know just sort of closing my
eyes and just feeling the heat of the
Sun you were trying to take walks and we
can we haven't had the best weather
there's people that are stuck in
apartments I think I think that is tough
because they're sort of they don't want
to be in a crowded elevator to get
downstairs you know and in and out so
maybe trying to do it during off-hours
so that they don't feel so panicky about
being and it's gonna confined you know
New York City press out there all right
wait and there online there are lots of
you know Facebook and Instagram post now
where people are doing dance parties
online so you got that on and just dance
around the house with the family a
little bit we can 15 20 minutes it
really much mood there's a in
dialectical behavioral therapy there is
a skill called opposite action and that
can be really helpful when you're
feeling really down to do the opposite
want to get under the covers and you
feel so down to turn on some music and
to dance around the house even if you're
not help it can really raise your mood I
also love going upside down so or not
not everybody loves it I had some Jimmy
ones like I hate the feeling of blood
rushing to my head I'm like yoga trapeze
in my office oh if I don't and I'm
traveling sometimes I'll just do a
headstand up against the wall people
don't have to be Yogi's to go upside
down you know you can even hang off of
your bed right and you know you can to
kind of like do a little bit of it back
then that's always helped me feel I
don't know if it's draining cortisol or
doing the knobs I'm not even sure why it
works but I love question yeah we're
rushing through your body that's
fantastic I love it so much that's all
I've heard so many tips so to kind of
summarize you know let's um in a
nutshell because I think these are these
are fabulous for now and they're
fabulous really you know we're at this
peak stress level and this is you know
worldwide that there are things that you
can do and certainly if you if these
techniques are not enough that should be
a trigger to get in touch with us
this absolutely ready touch with your
primary care doctor and everyone is
available through telemedicine portals
everybody's available just on the phone
I have noticed for me like I ran out
shocked my lawn guys just so I could
have a human to human conversation it
wasn't through the computer I was six
feet away they looked at me like crazy
like what are you doing something
outside talking Johnson you're far
enough away I just wanted to say hi and
make sure that they were doing okay and
kind of coping all right so I feel like
checking on neighbors you know when
we're being of service to other people
kind of de-emphasizes our own stress
level yes so I've seen a lot of people
get on the next door app to just say
like hey I'm available I can help I can
drop off groceries if you're elderly or
if somebody needs a roll of toilet paper
I have extra kind of a thing
there's even there's even some you know
at least where we are going to in New
York
there are lots of opportunities and you
can even get the kids involved to write
letters to elderly people are homebound
yeah yeah I just registered with New
York State to be doing free counseling
for people for the state so there's all
sorts of things looking at lumped in and
that's great it's great for the kids and
scrape to the parents and it really
helps with that kind of gratitude
mechanism which makes us all feel better
I love that one so I was gonna bring
that up is that to even end on this note
is it's the gratitude piece so we do a
lot of gratitude sharing on my team
calls I do it with my son and I feel
like the gratitude piece right to like
reduce stress get the mind focused on
something to be grateful for it and not
focus on the thing to be afraid of
mm-hmm
you know that certainly is one I am
incredibly grateful for you you've been
such a tremendous resource to the
fertility answers community to the
infertility community and now to hear
that of course I'm not surprised that
you're lending your services to your New
York State community you know to be
available I are just you're a gem of all
June yes thank you so much thank you for
having me it's been fantastic I are so
welcome so you're going to be able to
find this video on